cette devenir une grande chanteuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
aline mais en fait céline parce que
c'est un film fortement inspiré par la
vie de céline dion ça va sortir cet
automne stéphane et on a de nouveaux
détails souhait
lorsque valérie lemercier la comédienne
et réalisatrice du film a dévoilé la
bande annonce du film aligne environ
deux semaines lors d'une émission de
télé en france on était plutôt sceptique
au québec on se demandait qu'est ce que
c'est que ce film là où justesse que
c'est un film biographique est ce que
c'est une comédie est ce que c'est un
film qui se moque d'eux c'est l'illusion
est ce que c'est un hommage alors
valérie lemercier cette comédienne très
talentueux qu'on a découvert ici au
québec dans le film les visiteurs en
1993 et il fait tout dans cible si elle
qu'interprète céline à lille ne lâche
2,5 à à 50 ans c'est elle que réaliser
ce muller qui a engagé de nombreux
comédiens québécois dont sylvain marcel
qui interprète le rôle de rené angélil
et des fonds du québec quand la sodec a
investi dans ce film là une partie du
tournage que dieu à montréal alors là
elle accorder une entrevue valérie
lemercier au magazine paris match
une entrevue dans laquelle elle donne
toutes sortes d'informations très
intéressant premièrement ce monde est-ce
qu'elle a rencontré céline dion pour
parler de ce film là elle dit j'ai eu
l'occasion de le faire à plusieurs
reprises mais ça aurait été une minute
en deux portes alors j'ai préféré
travailler dans mon coin en pensant à
elle juillet écrit elle connaît mon
projet et j'ai lu récemment dans la
presse qu'elle avait hâte de découvrir
le film et qu'il espérait qu'il était
beau mais on se demande aussi est-ce que
c'est biographique est ce que c'est un
délai bien ce que c'est au juste que ce
film là edit j'ai voulu prendre une
distance avec céline c'est pour ça que
ça s'appelle aline mais quand même s'est
fortement inspiré par la vie de céline
dion
il ya quelques scènes inventé pour
rendre certains faits plus
cinématographique comme la demande en
mariage mais aucune me raconte le
contraire de ce qu est céline et ce
qu'elle raconte en entrevue c'est que lm
céline dion c'est une déclaration
d'amour de céline dion elle écoute
depuis l'album 2 paru en 1995 est-ce que
c'est elle qui chante également
dans la bande-annonce et sera bien
compte que c'est sûrement pas valérie
lemercier l'esisc elle dit lors de cette
entrevue dans paris match c'est à dire
ce n'est pas moi je n'ai pas une grande
voix on a auditionné une cinquantaine de
chanteuse parce que ce n'est pas la voix
de céline dion non plus celle qui a été
retenue elle dévoile son nom elle
s'appelle victoria si haut c'est une
chanteuse française de 34 ans que je
n'en différentes comédies musicales et
qui a participé à différents concours
j'ai retrouvé sur le web
en attendant la sortie du film prévue en
france en novembre on n'a pas de date
pour le québec mais j'ai retrouvé du
victoria si aucun interprète du céline
dion voici ce que ça donne mac
m thiès dessous
m
never before
à
[Musique]